Okay, first question, I will be getting a PET scan for the first time today and we'll follow
it with high dose IV vitamin C plus 1,200 milligrams of glutathione. There's a later question
about glutathione, too. A recommendation I recently received to help remove the radiation.
I've had the recurring thought that I should also do a coffee animal afterwards to support my liver,
but I don't know what will help or will overwhelm my body.
Let's talk about this first. The coffee animal is going to just support your liver detox pathways.
So this is one of the best ways to detoxify because remember, a coffee animal is going to stimulate
your parasympathetics. It's going to stimulate your immune system and thereby stimulate your detox
patient pathways. So if some people can't tolerate coffee animals very well,
but if you can tolerate a coffee animal, it's the best way to help support your liver.
Also, something that I would say is if you have access to a sauna, you want to help get rid of
stuff out of your body when you're exposed to radiation, when you're exposed to dyes, when you're
exposed to chemicals, when you're exposed to toxins. If you can do a sauna, then you're just detoxing
through your pores instead of through your liver. So you're taking burden off your liver,
drinking a lot of water can be very helpful, too. So think of those kind of things.
Go back to my seven phases of detoxification course using binders in the gut like charcoal
and sodium alginate and humate and humic acid and things like that can be also very helpful.
Why would you use glutathione? So I know there's been controversy about glutathione and cancer.
We've talked about this last week or the week before too. I used to be in the camp that I didn't want
to use glutathione with cancer. I've changed my mind on that with some different research that
have come out. Now I think glutathione is a positive per cancer. What is glutathione? It's your made
intracellular detoxification antioxidant. So what are oxidizing factors, oxidizing factors,
damage cells damage, DNA cause cancer, damage cell membranes, their causes of cancer,
oxidizing agents, reactive oxygen species, our causes of cancer. But the only caveat to that is
chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent. Well, it's a poison. We're basically trying to poison your
cancer cells. So if you were doing chemotherapy, then you wouldn't do glutathione. You wouldn't
use alphalopeic acid. You wouldn't use IV vitamin C while you're doing chemotherapy.
Well, why? You need to protect yourself. Well, I know, but you are purposely trying to poison
yourself with chemotherapy. I don't need that in a bad way. You are purposely trying to poison
your cancer cells when you're using an oxidizing agent like chemotherapy. So don't
negate. If you're choosing to do chemotherapy, well, then don't negate its ability by using a whole
bunch of nutritional antioxidants because they work and they will work by decreasing the
ability for chemotherapy to kill cells or at least wait 48 hours. So if you're doing IV vitamin C,
if you're doing glutathione, you're doing alphalopeic acid. If you're doing vitamin C, if you're doing
you know, higher dose, curcumin, things that are antioxidants that are so good for you because
they're antioxidants, you can't do them for at least the first 48 hours after receiving chemotherapy.
This person doesn't have a question about chemotherapy at all. They're talking about a PET scan and
detoxify the radiation and things. Well, glutathione is good to help with any detoxification including
radiation and such. So it is good. Now I know there's older information about glutathione
and well, glutathione can protect and help cancer cells. Well, then everything you're doing to
stimulate your body healthy is doing that same thing too. So I kind of don't agree with that
philosophy. So I do think that glutathione is beneficial for your cells. I mean, there's no doubt
about it. And I do think that it is going to protect your healthy cells and protect your immune cells.
So I think glutathione is a good thing to use.